Hola Muy Bienvenidos a la entrevista de
Franz 24 en español nos acompaña en esta
oportunidad ya era Jaguar y ella es
académica y escritora Palestina también
es analista política del centro de
pensamiento al chabaca ya era Jaguares
Muchas gracias por estar en la
entrevista de France 24 Gracias por
invitarme
gracias de nuevo yara desde finales de
2022 y en lo que llevamos de 2023 hemos
presenciado lo que algunos describen
como una suerte de recrudecimiento de la
violencia especialmente en Jerusalén
este y en la cisjordania ocupada sin
embargo es correcto hablar de
recrudecimiento o quizás es más correcto
hablar de cierta continuidad como
definiría usted la situación actual
creo que tenemos que entender que existe
una estructura de violencia continua en
Palestina y que en la mayoría de
momentos vemos Esta escalada de
violencia o una mayor intensificación de
la violencia que es ininterrumpida para
todos los palestinos que viven bajo la
ocupación bajo la colonización y creo
que Hay momentos en los que los
principales medios de comunicación se
interesan particularmente porque se
produce un acontecimiento o pasa algo en
particular lo que desencadena una
narrativa de que hay un recrudecimiento
de violencia o un nuevo ciclo de
violencia cuando en realidad esto no es
del todo cierto la verdad es que se
trata de una continuación y los
palestinos llevan más de siete décadas
sufriendo la colonización y la ocupación
israelíes
Diana indies
en este contexto la comunidad
internacional o al menos parte de ella
suele pedir siempre que se restablezca
la calma Pero hay una calma que
restablecer Cómo es la vida cotidiana de
los palestinos
cuando la comunidad internacional pide
calma está hablando de regresar al
status quo que es colonización y
ocupación para los palestinos la
realidad cotidiana de los palestinos es
que todos los aspectos de su vida están
controlados por el régimen israelí
estamos hablando de que la libertad de
movimiento la libertad de expresión la
simple capacidad de vivir como palestino
está completamente controlada por el
régimen israelí Así que es poco sincero
que la comunidad internacional pida que
se restablezca la calma porque en
realidad lo que pide es calma para los
israelíes y no calma para los palestinos
porque los palestinos no pueden vivir en
calma en paz o seguros mientras su
territorio esté ocupado Entonces tiene
razón al insinuar que se trata de una
petición poco sincera por parte de la
comunidad internacional
la narrativa de Israel lo que dice el
gobierno de Israel es que está en guerra
contra el terrorismo palestino bajo esta
premisa bajo esta idea qué tácticas
utiliza el gobierno israelí contra los
palestinos y a quienes afectan
el régimen israelí utiliza esta
narrativa del terrorismo básicamente
para deshumanizar a los palestinos y
deshumanizar la lucha Palestina por la
liberación y es una narrativa que
utiliza occidente los gobiernos
occidentales si no les gusta un pueblo o
si ven a un pueblo como inhumano
simplemente pueden llamarlo terrorista y
criminalizarlo esencialmente
así que para el régimen israelí Es una
herramienta muy útil la utilizan para
justificar la matanza diaria de
palestinos la utilizan para justificar
la continua ocupación y opresión de los
palestinos cuando en realidad los
palestinos están luchando y resistiendo
para sobrevivir en esta situación tan
injusta en la que se encuentra
ya era hemos estado viendo desde hace
semanas protestas masivas en contra de
la Reforma judicial de Benjamín y lo
hacen en reclamo de preservar la
democracia cómo observan los palestinos
estas protestas
los mismos manifestantes los medios de
comunicación israelíes y los medios
internacionales califican estas
protestas como prodemocráticas la
realidad es que el estado israelí no es
un estado democrático el estado israelí
gobierna a millones de palestinos que no
tienen absolutamente ninguna voz en Cómo
se gobiernan sus vidas Es un régimen de
segregación racial no se puede tener
democracia bajo un régimen de
segregación racial cuando uno de los
pueblos Un grupo se considera más
dominante que el otro y se le dan más
privilegios que al otro Así que en el
contexto de estas protestas en realidad
se trata de preservar la segregación
racial pero haciéndola mucho más
atractiva para los israelíes liberales
que existen en esa sociedad
no se da cuenta de que en estas
protestas se habla muy poco de la
ocupación y la colonización de Palestina
hay muy poco espacio para siquiera sacar
el tema por lo tanto estas protestas son
Realmente para preservar el statu quo y
no para provocar un gran cambio de
estatus
[Música]
hablemos de otro punto que me parece muy
importante porque las mujeres Siempre
han estado presentes y han actuado en
momentos cruciales de la historia
Palestina Hablemos del concepto de
interseccionalidad que es muy
ilustrativo en este caso porque las
mujeres palestinas sufren varias
opresiones Por ejemplo cómo lucha el
feminismo palestino contra la opresión
patriarcal la opresión colonial y
también contra esa violencia sistemática
de Israel que usted describe Israel
[Música]
creo que es un tema increíblemente
importante sobre todo por el Día
Internacional de la mujer que se celebra
en marzo en todo el mundo
las mujeres palestinas Siempre han
estado al frente de la resistencia
Palestina contra los colonos sionistas
el colonialismo son parte integral de la
sociedad y por tanto parte integral de
la resistencia y tiene razón al afirmar
que las mujeres palestinas se enfrentan
a una doble opresión no solo por el
colonialismo sino también por las
estructuras patriarcales de la sociedad
Palestina desde el principio el régimen
israelí ha tratado realmente de
exasperar esas estructuras patriarcales
existentes por lo que para las
feministas palestinas como yo es crucial
que entendamos la liberación pa dentro
de un marco interseccional uno que
entienda que hay muchas capas de
opresión y que el régimen sionista
utiliza la opresión de género la
opresión de clase entre otras muchas
formas de opresión para mantener al
pueblo palestino sometido y reprimido
porque por supuesto les conviene que las
mujeres palestinas que son la mitad de
la población sigan sometidas por lo
tanto la lucha feminista Palestina es en
gran medida parte integral o Debería ser
en gran medida parte de la lucha de
liberación general porque no se puede
tener una Palestina libre cuando las
mujeres palestinas no son libres
muchas veces las críticas al Estado de
Israel o a sus políticas hacia el pueblo
palestino son tildadas de antisemitas
esto provoca algún tipo de silencio en
ciertos países
absolutamente creo que el antisemitismo
se ha convertido en un arma que
perjudica a las luchas anti racistas hay
una diferencia Clara entre la ideología
sionista y el judaísmo la ideología
sionista es una ideología política que
pretende Establecer un estado judío en
la tierra de Palestina que privilegia a
los judíos israelíes sobre los
palestinos autóctonos Mientras que el
judaísmo es una religión
Así que son dos cosas diferentes y
deberían considerarse como tales y la
crítica e Israel no es en absoluto una
crítica al pueblo judío la crítica a
Israel es una crítica a una entidad
política una entidad política que ha
sido reconocida por cometer el crimen de
segregación racial por muchas
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos por
los mismos palestinos por tanto son dos
cosas muy distintas y separadas pero
lamentablemente se ha insinuado lo
contrario en un intento de proteger a
Israel al régimen israelí de las
críticas de la comunidad internacional
ya era para empezar a hablar de paz Qué
es lo primordial que hay que garantizar
no podemos hablar de paz mientras no se
hable de Justicia cualquier debate sobre
la paz en la palabra justicia o sin el
concepto de Justicia es una paz falsa
sabemos por la historia sabemos por la
experiencia que cuando muchos actores
han hablado de paz antes esencialmente
Estados Unidos o los países europeos lo
han hecho en un marco que preserva el
régimen Israel y el status quo esto
significa esencialmente que los
palestinos ceden que los palestinos son
sometidos así que sin justicia no se
puede hablar de paz y la justicia Es
realmente el primer paso hacia ésta
estamos llegando al final de la
entrevista Así que quiero pedirle un
mensaje no solo para los palestinos que
están resistiendo sino también para la
comunidad internacional community
los palestinos van a seguir resistiendo
a la opresión y a la colonización hasta
el último momento Y seguirán haciéndolo
Y puede que hayan inspirado realmente a
personas de todo el mundo por su
constancia a su vez los palestinos se
inspiran en las luchas de otros pueblos
especialmente las de América Latina del
sur Global
en Latinoamérica
y realmente ya es hora de que la
comunidad internacional responsabilice
al régimen israelí y deje de ofrecerle
impunidad por las continuas violaciones
contra el pueblo palestino porque por
supuesto la liberación de Palestina no
se trata solo de Palestina se trata de
justicia y Libertad en todo el mundo
quiero darle las gracias por estar en la
entrevista de Franz 24
Gracias por invitarme gracias de nuevo a
nuestra audiencia le invitamos como
siempre a que sigan informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación también
24.com y no olviden que pueden escuchar
esta entrevistas y muchas más en Spotify
en la entrevista Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]